Oi! What's happened here?
Sand.
Sabotage.
Wrecking.
Deliberate.
What's at the back of it?
Who did it?
I know how the law stands.
You broke a contract, therefore
you broke the law.
But it's everywhere - look at the street.
I paid my money to look at the pictures.
"Just a song at twilight."
If I want to sit in the dark
I can do it at 'ome.
- Yes, free of charge.
- Yes.
I think it's a blinkin' shame, robbing
the poor people like that.
We've got to have our money back.
It's an act of providence, like... an
earthquake, or a thunderbolt.
Or a baby.
Will you kindly not interfere?
We've got to have our money back.
I'm so sorry I'm late, Mrs Verloc...
...but I had a hell of a time trying to eat
my egg on toast in the dark.
Half of it's in my ear now!
Nothing more or less than the Queen...
They want their money back,
but we can't afford it.
I do wish Mr Verloc would come.
Rotten place, anyhow. Can't
even see the pictures.
- They're getting nasty.
- Nasty? Hmph.
Leave 'em to me.
Hey, you.
What's all this about?
Lend me your flashlight, Jake.
I want my money back.
Is it our fault if the light fails?
Supposing you were a policeman
and got hit over the nut?
Do you think the government would
ask for their money back?
I paid for my seat.
Yes. And what about the one
you put your feet on?
Carl! When did you get home?
I haven't been out.
You weren't in twenty minutes ago.
I came and called up the stairs.
I was asleep.
Why are you shining that torch on me?
Can't you switch on the
light, or something?
We can't - it's failed.
What?
The fuse gone, then?
No, it's everywhere - in the
streets and the trams.
And the audience downstairs
wants their money back.
They're making a terrible row about it.
Well, give it back.
We... we can't possibly afford it.
Oh, yes, we can.
You must be crazy.
It'll clear us right out.
You're always saying we don't
cover expenses.
That's all right.
It doesn't pay to antagonise
the public.
I've got some money coming in.
Goon.
Well, it's for you to say.
If we're going to be generous,
let's do it properly.
Come on downstairs and make
a speech about it.
No, no. They're used to you.
You do it.
All right.
I still think you're crazy.
It's an Act of God, I tell yer.
And what do you call an
Act of God?
I call your face one, and you won't
get your money back on that.
Now, if a plane were to come along
and drop a bomb on you...
...that would be an unfriendly act, within
the meaning of the Act.
But if the juice dries up
of its own accord...
...that's an Act of Providence.
As laid down in the Act of
William the Fourth.
Where an Act is defined
as "any activity"...
...“actuated by actual action."
No wonder the blinkin'
lights went down!
It's a moot point.
I'll moot point 'em.
Make 'em pay!
- That's right, ma.
- Yes.
We want our money back.
And how are you going to get it?
Apply sanctions?
Are you familiar with the details
of the Covenant?
If you'd studied Article 257...
...paragraph 24, line six...
...Sanction B. It says, definitely, "no"!
Oh.
Yes. You didn't know that, did you?
You're all ignorant.
Now, if you take my advice you'll go off
home, because there's nothing doing here.
Now, go on - get off.
What do you think you're doing?
Just lending a hand.
I thought I told you not to interfere?
I've been delivering a little counter-attack.
Look, they're on the run.
Well they can come right back.
Listen, ladies and gentlemen, you're
going to get your money back.
Don't give in now - I'll stand by you.
I'd be afraid to go and stand
by your apple stall.
Ladies and gentlemen, I've been
speaking to Mr Verloc.
And since you're all regular patrons
and good friends...
...he's going to let you have
your money back.
There'll be no money back, I
tell you. Go on, get off.
Please! Don't pay any attention to him!
I tell you, you're crazy!
I had it all fixed.
Will you mind your own business?
Of all the obstinate people...
If you don't go away, I'll...
call the police.
Renee.
Start refunding the patrons
their money.
Oh!
Over here, Pat!
Oi! None of that. You 'aven't
been in before - 'op it!
Thank you for your trouble.
I'm sure you meant well.
Not at all. I like trouble.
Left the conference
absolutely mortified!
- How many?
- Two seats, please.
Two? Right. Thank you.
- How many?
- Two shillings, please.
Two shillings?
Right.
Wait for your change, please.
- How many?
- One.
Thank you.
How many?
None, thanks.
Oh, the vegetables is all ready
for dishing up.
Please tell Mrs Verloc, miss.
Oh! There you are, ma'am.
I've got to hurry home now, 'cause me husband's
havin' trouble with his kidneys again.
And I can't leave 'im for long.
Your young brother's lookin' after 'em.
- What, the kidneys?
- No, the vegetables!
Oh, Stevie. Have you done
all this by yourself?
Oh, come on. Don't be so modest.
Well...
...we didn't have to pay them back
their money, after all.
Oh, Stevie! Sorry, sorry.
Always that woman, Mrs Jones, manages
to make the cabbage brown.
I'm always telling her you
like things green.
I'll make you a salad.
Stevie, run next door and get a
nice big head of lettuce.
Long or round?
- I like long best.
- Whichever's freshest.
Tell them to charge it.
We nearly wouldn't have been able to afford
lettuce if we'd payed them back.
You didn't seem very interested
when I told you.
I mean...
...why were you so keen to pay
them back at all?
No, it's not that.
Only... anything for quiet.
I don't like attention being
drawn to us like that.
Good evening, Mrs Verloc. Forgive me for
butting in on your private affairs...
...but this prize specimen didn't appear
to know whether he wanted long, round...
...square or oblong lettuce. So I
brought a selection.
I distinctly said "long
ones" - you know I did.
Did you? I thought you said "long ones".
I SAID "long ones"!
Oh, good evening, Mr Verloc.
So you came home just in time
to see the trouble, eh?
Me? I've been in all the afternoon.
But I could have sworn I saw you
come in, just about...
Well, you were wrong.
I didn't know anything about it
until you woke me. Did I?
No.
He was lying down upstairs.
I had to call him.
Sorry. My mistake, I suppose.
Well, here we are.
I thought someone was
committing a murder!
Someone probably is.
From the scream there.
Stevie, hop on a chair and
fix that fan light.
Look out George Arliss doesn't
bite you, Steve!
Well, good night all.
All right, lady. I'll look round
the market tomorrow.
Thank you.
Do you mind if I knock off
early tonight, guv?
- Okay, Ted.
- Thank you.
Good night, boys.
That feller seems to knock
off whenever he likes.
All right. We'll put someone onto that.
Well, Sergeant - you saw what
happened tonight.
- Yes, sir.
- Anything your end?
I'm not certain, but I could have sworn I saw
Verloc come back in the middle of it all.
Later, when I challenged him, he said
he'd never been out at all.
His wife confirmed it.
Naturally. She would if she's in it.
You'd better find some way
of talking to her.
Now, listen, Spencer. The Home Office
have been on...
...and they're scared something worse than
tonight's job may happen.
What's the idea, sir? What's the
point of all this wrecking?
Making trouble at home to take our minds
off what's going on abroad.
Same as in a crowd. One man
treads on your toe...
...and while you're arguing with him,
his pal picks your pocket.
Who's behind it?
Ah, they're the people that you
and I will never catch.
It's the men they employ
that we're after.
Don't you know that's very dangerous?
What?
Leaving stuff like that lying about.
Supposing you or me was to
break our leg on that.
You'd be very pleased with
yourself, I suppose.
That would depend whether
it was your leg or mine.
Can't tempt you, I suppose? Oranges,
very nice today. Good for the feet.
Hello, guv. Going to the pictures?
As a matter of fact I'm off
to a trade show.
Well, pick us a good one, then. You
know - plenty of murders.
This love stuff makes me sick.
The women like it, though.
He's just going.
Oh, then tell him not to come back too
late, 'cause we're going out.
I'm told to tell you not to come back too
late because we're both going out.
I'll be back as soon as I can.
A penny each pineapple.
Pineapples a penny each.
Robbie, come here!
What's them bubbles, Dad?
Has the fish got 'iccups?
You'd have 'iccups if you had
to live on ants' eggs.
- They're funny looking things.
- Yes.
They're funny looking things.
It'll take three like that to make soup for
the Lord Mayor's banquet next Saturday.
Think of that.
They say it's digestible, though.
Hmph. There's a thing with a moustache.
I hope you're satisfied with
last night's show.
It wasn't as easy as it looked.
I had to spend money, too.
No doubt.
A neat job, though.
The sort of thing to make people sit up.
I think you'll agree I've
earned my money?
I hope you didn't mind my asking
for it in pound notes?
You made London laugh.
When one sets out to put the
fear of death into people...
...it's not helpful to make them laugh.
We're not comedians.
It's not my fault if they are such fools.
Londoners are not fools.
They laughed because they realised what
happened last night was laughable.
They did right to laugh...
...this time.
What do you mean?
Mr Verloc.
You will be paid your money
when you've earned it.
I don't follow.
My dear Verloc.
I once read a sign in Piccadilly Circus,
calling it the centre of the world.
I think you'd better pay a visit there,
in a couple of days' time.
Leave a small parcel in the cloakroom
at the Underground station.
What sort of a parcel?
Oh, I don't know.
Let's say... a parcel of fireworks.
I couldn't do it.
I'm not going to be connected with
anything that means loss of life.
You'll have to get somebody else.
I won't touch it.
Very well, then, Mr Verloc.
If you think you're so well-off that...
You know I'm not.
You know my position.
All right, then.
You'll be payed your money when...
In any case, if you're so fussy
about doing it yourself...
...surely you have some kind friends
who would help you?
Now, don't be so silly.
Go and see this man.
He's a very nice old gentleman, and he
makes lovely fireworks.
I'll try and see him.
And don't forget the date.
Saturday next.
Lord Mayor's Show day,
Lots of people.
Do you want me to come and report?
Thanks, no.
If your report itself is...
loud enough...
...it won't be necessary.
Which is the way out, please?
Thank you.
This bivalve's rate of fertility
is extremely high.
After laying a million eggs the female
oyster changes her sex.
Hmph! I don't blame her!
Excuse me, can I help you?
Oh, urn, thank you.
Cor, its feet are cold!
Isn't it fat?
You'd be fat too if you were fed corn,
and bits of bread all day long.
Why, if it isn't Stevie and Mrs Verloc.
Ooh, it's Ted. Look, Ted!
Yes, it always is.
Fat, isn't it? Ought to
eat more fruit, eh?
You and your fruit, that's
our lunch today.
Why, is that all? How about a nice juicy
steak with me? What about it?
I'm all for it.
Stevie.
Good, where shall we go?
I'd like to go to Simpson's.
Boy I know's uncle took him there once.
Don't be silly, Stevie. We're going to the
Corner House or a tea shop.
Oh, don't be too hard, Mrs V.
Let's make it Simpson's.
Come on.
Have you ever been here before?
No, never.
Oh, Stevie - look what you're doing!
You're pulling the table.
I saw a picture once, where a chap snatched
the tablecloth off the table...
...and left everything standing on it.
You ought to try that at home one day.
He did.
All this is very expensive, isn't it?
Yes. It looks like it, doesn't it?
I've got a pound note, if you want it?
It's all right.
Now. Steve. Setting aside the
steak for a moment...
...we have here before us
oysters, caviar...
...smoked salmon, fried, grilled
or boiled sole.
I'll have a...
Roast saddle of mutton, Kentish
chicken pudding...
...boiled silverside, roast sirloin...
...chops, steaks, grilled kidneys
or roast duck.
I think Stevie'd like a nice
poached egg on toast.
And I'll have a mixed salad.
Here, drink this.
Poached egg? Here at Simpson's?
Why, that's enough to make the
roast beef turn in its gravy!
Oh.
Three bullocks roasted whole,
and a cup of coffee.
Sirloins at number eight.
When did you come over
from America?
About a year ago.
Business wasn't too good over there.
That's funny.
People used to go over to the States because
business wasn't too good over here.
How are things working out now?
Not too good, hmm?
Not terribly.
I thought I hadn't noticed you
turning people away.
It's hard to make a one-man
business pay these days.
Unless you run a sideline.
Has Mr Verloc a sideline?
No, but we're quite satisfied
with things as they are.
Just one happy little family?
Just one happy little family.
Mr Verloc's very kind to Stevie.
And that means a lot
to Stevie's sister?
It means everything.
Now, here we are.
Good morning, sir.
No fat for you, as usual?
You see I don't forget, sir.
Haven't seen you for a long time.
Do I look as though I don't like fat?
What's the big idea?
What idea?
First, pretending never to have
been here before.
Second, affording to come
here on your salary.
That's what everyone would like to know.
There's a mystery about me!
Come to think of it, there's a mystery
about most people.
Haven't you got some
terrible secret?
Never mind about that!
What goes on after hours in
that cinema of yours?
Deeds of darkness!
Does your husband go on
mysterious journeys?
He does - wearing false whiskers.
Ah-ha! That means there's another
woman in his life.
What's the joke?
If you only knew him.
He's the quietest, most harmless,
home-loving person.
Well? What luck with Mrs Verloc?
She knows nothing, sir.
Nothing at all.
What makes you think so?
She has a straight answer to everything.
Besides, her manner.
Pretty woman?
- What's that got to do with it, sir'?
- Ah, I know.
I'm too tender-hearted myself.
Especially where women are concerned.
What about Verloc?
I'm not certain.
But if he is mixed up in this he's
not giving himself away.
I'm not so sure about that.
- Your assistant... er... what's his name?
- Hollingshead.
Hollingshead was signalled by you this
morning to follow this man.
Yes, sir.
Well, er... just reach me
that paper, will you?
This is his report. Telephoned from
a call box, ten minutes ago.
"Verloc went to the zoo aquarium."
"Evidently by appointment."
"And met a certain foreign individual,
who handed him a paper."
"He then proceeded to go to 65
Liverpool Road, Islington."
"Which is a bird shop."
"I'm waiting for him to come out, and
will report again later on."
- Islington?
- Exactly.
Doesn't mean much to me, either.
But I can't understand, madam.
One of my best songbirds.
It sang all day before you
purchased it.
Perhaps in a few days
it will settle down.
Nothing won't make it settle
down. I've tried all ways.
Whistling to it...
...clapping me 'ands...
...frying bacon. No use.
It just sits there and makes
me look silly.
Not the bird's fault, I assure
you, madam.
Isn't it?
I'll have my two-and-nine, please.
And there's yer bird back.
I want a canary for company.
Perhaps I can make him sing?
There, now.
You sure it was 'im?
Listen again.
I see his beak open.
Of course you did.
There's a good boy.
Now, don't forget - plenty of watercress
and you must whistle to him.
Me, whistle?
Perhaps you'd like me to sit in the cage,
and him do the housework?
Yes, of course. You want something from
my other department, don't you?
Mmm hmm? This way.
My daughter.
Much better than having
strangers doing for you.
Strangers... too inquisitive,
you know?
Now, where are my keys?
Tut, tut, tut, tut.
How very careless.
She oughtn't to let the child
play up here.
Very dangerous.
There you are... no father,
no discipline.
What can you expect?
Is the little girl's father dead?
I don't know.
He might be. Heh.
I don't know. Nobody knows.
My daughter would like
to know, too.
But there you are.
It's her cross, and she
must bear it.
We all have our cross to bear.
Mmm hmm?
Everything there looks pretty harmless.
You are right, my friend.
But...
...if I were to mix, say...
...a little tomato sauce...
...with some strawberry jam.
Then...
I gather from our mutual friend...
That Saturday is the day. And the
hour, 1:45.
But, how do I start the mechanism?
Oh, you leave that to me.
By the time you receive it, everything
will have been set in motion.
- Uh huh.
- You seem a little nervous.
Mmm.
Don't be afraid.
Say to yourself "there is one
man who envies you".
Envies me?
I've been a fighter always, until now.
But alas, I'm no longer wanted
in the front line.
I must keep the fighters... supplied.
- But I would rather be in your shoes.
- Hm.
My dear!
Just look here.
Yes, yes. Perhaps you're right.
I must have put it there myself.
Oh.
There, there. No harm done.
Well, I...
...think everything is quite clear.
Slap me hard! Grandads
been very naughty.
Look there! What's he doing?
He might be watching me.
Why not?
They probably know too much already.
They'll raid you one day.
I shall give them a nice warm
welcome, if they do.
He didn't see me.
On Saturday - without fail, sir.
Two canaries in a nice cage,
with a very deep tray.
Don't forget, Saturday at 1:45.
Good day, sir.
Good day.
That child again.
And now, sir.
I want a nice singing canary.
A canary. You say it and my dear little
birds, at once, answer for themselves.
Of course, I realise he wasn't really a
greengrocer's assistant at all.
I mean, a greengrocer's assistant can hardly
afford to lunch at Simpson's, can he?
He's really quite well off.
And he's there to learn the business.
It's one of a big chain, that shop.
If you ask me, I believe he's the son
of the man who owns them.
How'd you like a job
selling fruit, Stevie?
I wouldn't mind with Ted.
He makes it all sound fun.
Wouldn't it be grand to have steak
whenever you like?
Crumbs, I'd have it three times a day!
You'd soon get sick of it.
Bet I wouldn't. I don't see how you could
get sick of things to eat.
'Cept poached eggs.
What's the matter with
poached eggs?
I think they're the worst
things in the world.
I bet Ted doesn't eat them.
I'm sure he does.
I bet he doesn't, they're
beneath his dignity.
I don't think Ted's so
terribly dignified.
Well, he's too dignified
to eat eggs.
Hey, now! See - you're bunching it up!
Oh, now! It's all right, Stevie.
Do you think Ted'll come
with us and sail it?
He might if you ask him.
He's more likely to if you ask him.
Sailing boats is fun.
I like it.
But Ted knows about
all sorts of things.
Gangsters and burglars
and everything.
- How does he know?
- He reads about 'em.
He says gangsters are not nearly so
frightening as you'd think.
Some of them are quite
ordinary looking.
Like you and me and Mr Verloc.
Perhaps he's right.
After all, if gangsters looked
like gangsters...
the police would soon get after them,
wouldn't they, I mean?
Sixpence, please.
Thank you.
Is Mr Verloc in?
- Was he expecting you?
- Yes.
- Do you know your way through?
- Yes, I think so.
- Pass one, Jack.
- Thank you.
I have an appointment with Mr Verloc.
- Do you know your way through?
- No.
You go right through the theatre.
- Pass one, Jack.
- Thank you.
Apples a pound there!
Lady there, Ted.
Yes, madam. What can I do for you?
Pound of those apples, please.
I have to slip away in a minute.
Maybe I won't be bothering you any
more again after tonight.
Thank you.
Keep an eye out, Jim, will you?
One balcony, please.
Pass one, Jack.
"I'm glad you found this."
"It's the most important of the lot.
I'll burn it, too."
"Oh, huh, allow me."
"Oh, thank you."
"Well - all our troubles are over now."
"Oh!"
"Ch! Oh! Oh!"
- "What's that?"
- "What's what?"
"Look out!"
"Ah-Ooh! Ah-ooh!"
"Hold the phone!"
"Come on, Sidney."
Hello, Ted. Where are you going?
Just going to have a word
with Mr Verloc.
Oh, he doesn't talk through
loudspeakers.
Is that what's in there?
Oh, it's only the screen - not
much to look at.
“Oh, Oh?
Where does that lead to?
To our front room. You
remember, when it fell open?
I'll give old Mr V a surprise!
- "It's the door!"
- "Come out of that."
"I'm your nephew."
"Oh, are you?"
"Oh, don't fiddle about, that's no good.
Leave it to me, I'll get it out of him."
"Don't you do that to me!"
"Well, don't you talk like that to me."
"Remember, I'm yer uncle..."
Not at all.
I'm only too glad to pay what
the job's worth.
Well, I don't see anything against it.
I'll call in tomorrow, about
eleven o'clock.
And afterward...
I'll settle with you...
...when you've done the job.
Of course...
...if the Arsenal lose to Birmingham on
Saturday, I shan't be so pleased.
Arsenal?
I don't follow.
No, no, I know you don't follow Arsenal,
but they're a good bet.
Believe me. Don't forget, I... filled
in about ten coupons.
Stands me in at about
fifteen bob!
So I'd better...
Why... I know him!
What were you doing up there?
Who is he?
Well, he's from from the
fruiterer next door.
I know him, all right, but...
What happened?
I was showing Ted the back of the
screen and the loudspeakers.
Wasn't that all right?
Hope I didn't hurt you?
You never know, you know?
Well, Mr Verloc... no harm
done, I hope!
I must be getting back to the shade
of the old apple tree.
Sorry.
Good night, all.
Good night.
That is Detective Sergeant Spencer
of Scotland Yard.
But who's he after?
You're having us on?
But what are we going to
do about it?
But he's connected with the fruit
store next door, I tell you!
Spencer got me my last stretch - the
one I'm on licence from now.
What are we going to do about it?
One thing.
This job is off, out, finished.
We go quick from here, and scatter.
And keep scattered.
And if he comes here again, tell him you
don't know where we live.
Say we've gone abroad -
anything you like!
Yesterday - at Simpson's...
...when you had lunch with
that fellow.
With Ted, you mean?
Remember what he said to you.
Did he ask you any questions
about yourself?
About me?
None that I can think of. Why?
Because he's a detective from
Scotland Yard.
That's why.
Spying on us - on me.
Through you.
But... why should he? What is
there to find out?
Well, I'm all right.
It must be one of those fellows
who came here tonight.
But you said he was spying on you.
No, not me.
This place, I meant.
Well, if he has anything against anybody,
why didn't he come straight to you?
You'd help him.
I'll talk to "Mr Detective Ted".
No, no, no. I'll speak to him myself.
- Haven't been cleaned all day.
- Righto, guv'nor.
- Where's Ted?
- He's gorn.
Has he gone to Scotland Yard?
Sorry, Mr Verloc.
'Course, I didn't like the idea but I
couldn't refuse. See, it was official.
Mmm. But why? What's wrong?
Did they say what it was about?
Not so far as I know.
You must have been showing some
funny sort of films, I dare say.
You know, perhaps a bit too "hot"?
Was he there?
Post.
I was trying to get hold of him since
first thing this morning.
Wasn't there anybody there
to answer?
No.
Well, it's too late to stop him now.
He's gone outwith an order.
All right.
An old man just left this.
I thought he must have
made a mistake.
No, no... th-that's all right.
It's only a pair of birds for Stevie.
I was just phoning about it.
You're terribly good to him.
Not to you?
You're good to him, you're good
to me. You know that.
Yes, I know.
What made you think of it?
Oh... someone made the suggestion.
Go and call him, will you?
Stevie?
What are you doing up there?
There's a surprise for you inside.
- What is it?
- Go and see.
There was no one on the door.
Forgive me for busting in like this.
We're getting used to it.
I'm afraid we've nothing showing
at this early hour.
I'm sorry, Mrs Verloc, but I'm
here on business.
Same business as last night?
Mrs Verloc, there's nothing
personal in all this.
Isn't there?
You had us fooled all right.
Trying to make Stevie and me
think you were a friend.
Do you think I enjoyed it?
- Then, why did you...
- Listen.
I asked to be taken off this
job this morning.
You can guess why.
But it's not as easy as that.
In my job you have to do
as you're told.
And what have you been told?
If it's about the men who came
here last night...
...my husband had nothing
to do with it.
You'd better realise that.
They came here on business.
About the cinema.
That's just it...
...you've no idea what their
business was.
Whatever it was, I'm sure my husband
hasn't done anything wrong.
I hope you're right.
Why do you say it like that?
Because we believe there's something going
on here connected with sabotage.
Sabota...
That blackout the other night.
Do you remember?
Well, my husband hasn't anything
to do with sabotage.
He told me that night he'd
been in all evening.
That wasn't true.
I saw him come back with
my own eyes.
I don't believe it.
You're making things very
difficult for me.
I'm afraid I've got to ask you
a lot of questions.
Now, about those men...
But I've told you before, he's the most
harmless person in the whole world.
He wouldn't do anything to...
Did these men arrive together
or one by one?
- Did you recognise any of them?
- No.
Are you quite certain you didn't know
one of them by sight?
- I don't think I ever saw any of them.
- They seemed to know their way around.
Stevie!
They're beauties.
Which one's the hen?
You'll have to wait 'til one of them
lays an egg.
Wouldn't it fool everybody if one
day the gent laid an egg?
Gosh, wouldn't that be funny?
You're right.
Er, by the way, has that two-reeler gone
over to The Canterbury yet?
Oh, there's plenty of time.
Mmm, I was just wondering.
Maybe you could take it along now?
Because... there's another little job I
want doing at the same time.
You know, kill two birds
with one stone.
Not my birds!
No, no. They'll be here when
you come back.
No, it's er... that er...
...projector gadget wants seeing to.
Harris out at Watford says he'll do it
cheaper than they will in town.
But he can't come right
away and fetch it...
...so, what they do is this.
You leave it in the cloakroom
at Piccadilly Circus.
Harris picks it up - at half past one.
But can he get it without the ticket?
Oh, that's all right. You leave the
ticket with the man.
Harris knows me. We've done this before.
- You'd better get along now.
- Well, there's no hurry.
- You'll have to walk all the way.
- Walk? What for'?
You know! You can't take film tins
in public vehicles.
Oh, yes, I forgot.
You needn't tell your sister that you're
going as far as Piccadilly.
You know what she is. Always thinking
you are going to get run over.
Oh, she needn't worry.
I wash. I don't.
Tails it is!
For God's sake, why don't you go?!
I mean, hurry up. You might be late.
Don't forget, it's got to be there
by 1:30 at the latest.
- Hello Steve. What have you got there?
- I'm taking a two-reeler over to The Canterbury.
Hmm. “Bartholomew the Strangler”. That
sounds a juicy one. Have you seen it?
- Fourteen times!
- Must be quite a wrench parting from it?
- Well, so long, "Bartholomew".
- So long.
- Careful of the crossings.
- I can look after myself, can't I?
- Oh, Steve. Ls Mr Verloc in?
- Yes, I just left him.
I'm afraid I've had to impose on you, Mr Verloc.
I couldn't afford to let you in on this.
Now I can put my cards
on the table.
I've come here to ask for your
help - nothing more.
I see.
About those men who were
here the other night...
...when I dropped in myself.
I've been instructed to get a little information about them.
We'd be very grateful if you'd help us.
Well, any help I can give,
then of course.
About yourself, Mr Verloc. When did you
first come to this country?
- Can I get you a drink or something?
- Not now, thanks.
We'll, I've got to think, now.
Let's see...
Perhaps it would be better if you put it
down on paper. Just a formality.
Would you find a pen and ink? We could start right away.
You know, “I, Carl Anton Verloc... ”.
Now, ladies and gentlemen. I want
to ask you a question.
- What is it causes teeth to fall out?
- Why, a punch on the jaw!
The process of decay - inevitable in
all human organisms.
But decay can be arrested, instantaneously
arrested. And by what?
- A copper.
- Yes, exactly. But...
...if I may say so, by rather more than one
copper - by a few coppers.
I have here in my hand, a tube of that
remarkable preparation, Salvodont.
"Toothache".
Sixpence for the small tube, and a shilling for
the large tube, containing four times as much.
Now let me give you just
a little demonstration.
Now, if somebody... Ah! I see
here a young gentleman...
...who will, I'm sure, be happy
to assist me.
- No, I wouldn't.
- Yes, you would.
Come on - bung him up.
- In the chair, sir, if you don't mind.
- But I...
- Allow me to relieve you of the toffee, eh?
- It isn't toffee and I...
All right, all right, all right! Stay where you are.
Don't get excited. Now then...
...here we are. The first thing to do is take
the tube in the left hand and remove the cap.
Like so. Then we pick up a toothbrush, and
we squeeze some of the Salvodont...
...along the bristles, like so. Then, I want
you to observe, ladies and gentlemen...
- ...that the young gentleman's teeth are very dirty.
- They are not!
Yes, they are. Now, come along. Open your
mouth, that's a good boy.
We now proceed to use the brush.
Now with your ordinary commercial dentrifices,
what 'appens? It is either too gritty...
...and takes all the enamel orf - or it
ain't, and it don't take nothing orf!
But with Salvodont, that's
the 'appy medium.
Neither too strong, nor too weak. It
performs the functions that nature forgot.
It cleanses the teeth, refreshes the mouth
and removes all traces of 'alitosis.
- Alley... what?
- "Bad breath" to you, sir.
- Same to you.
- Thank you, I don't need it.
Come on. There you are, now. Relax,
sonny - don't be afraid.
Now, ladies and gentlemen. You will observe
that I have, unfortunately, disarranged...
...the young gentleman's hair. But
that is easily attended to.
Now, I have here, a bottle of Glosswell.
A shilling for that size.
But I have a large size - four times the
size - which is only eighteen pence.
I will now give you a demonstration
of how it's used.
You put it on the 'air
like that, you see?
It's remarkable stuff, which is guaranteed
to give the appearance...
...of patent leather to the
human thatch.
You are now "groomed for stardom",
as they say.
Go on, buzz off, you little basket. Go on.
What do you want? Go on hop it!
Souvenirs for the Lord Mayor's Show!
Hey, where are you going? Go on, back to
your place! Go on. Go on. Go on!
Go on, son. Get right back.
Here they come.
I say, do you think we'll get to
Piccadilly Circus by 1:30?
Yes, 1:30 in the morning. You got
to meet a young lady there?
Here, you can't bring those there in a public vehicle.
They're films, ain't they?
Yes.
Then they're flammable. Go on -
hop off, big boy.
But I've got to get to Piccadilly. Can't I
leave them out on the platform or somewhere?
Ah... it's “Bartholomew the Strangler”. Oh,
well, as it's you Bartholomew, me old feller...
...you can stay - as long as you promise not
to set about me or any of the passengers.
Thank you.
Well, now. Everything seems to be all right.
Will you have your drink after all?
No, thanks.
Come in.
Oh, excuse me. Will you ring
up "Whitehall 1212"?
May I use your phone?
Put me through to Superintendent
Talbot, please.
Spencer here, sir.
A whole busload of people have been
blown up in the West End.
- How awful.
- What time?
Why do you ask?
Well, after all, I can't be in two places
at the same time, can I?
I suppose not.
I may be back, later on.
- Got on to anything?
- I'm not sure.
Well, make up your mind.
What is it anyway?
"Bartho... ". "Bartholomew" something?
Well, that's a film tin, isn't it?
I thought you said Verloc hadn't been
out since this morning.
He hadn't.
Well, you'd best go back there and...
- ...see if that's one of their films.
- You want me, sir?
Yes, yes. You'd better join Hollingshead
at the bird shop.
Yes, sir.
Don't go inside. Just keep
your eyes open.
- I will, sir.
- All right, Spencer - cut off.
Is that anything to do with it,
Mr Spencer?
“Bartholomew the Strangler”.
That's a film tin, isn't it?
No. Sardines.
News! Street bomb sensation!
Late extra news!
Street bomb sensation!
He's all right. He can take care of himself.
You've got nothing to worry about.
Late extra news! Street bomb sensation!
Big bomb sensation!
- Give me a penny.
- Late extra news! Street bomb sensation!
Late extra news! Late extra news!
Street bomb sensation!
- Look at that.
- Look, the lady's fainted.
Give her air.
I want Mr Verloc.
I want to see Mr Verloc.
I didn't mean any harm to
come to the boy.
Come on, we've got to
think of tomorrow.
You'll need all your wits about you,
if they get on to me.
You must answer a fellow.
Do be reasonable.
What would it have been...
if you had lost me?
That swine in the aquarium...
...silly jeering dangerous brute with
no more sense than...
You didn't know. Quite right too.
I'm not the chap to...
worry a woman...
...that's fond of me.
You have no business to know.
You'll have to pull yourself
together, my girl.
What's done can't be undone.
You go to bed now.
What you want is a good cry.
I know how you feel.
Do you think it doesn't touch me?
Do you think I fixed it so
that he'd be killed?
No, but I tell you who did.
Your Scotland Yard friend from
next door - Ted. Blame him.
I'd have carried the thing myself, but
he was hanging around watching, spying.
I couldn't get away.
Listen... It's done, now...
...and there's the future...
Perhaps... I don't know?
Perhaps, if we...
...had a kid of our own?
"Who killed Cock Robin?"
Everything's dished up. Young Stevie
ain't in, but I've laid for him.
Well, I'm getting along now.
"Who who who who whooo
killed Cock Robin?"
"Who killed Cock Robin?"
"Who got him with a shot and
put him on the spot?"
Pulled yourself together a bit?
That's better.
Never green. Why can't that woman
cook green stuff any better?
Surely she's been long enough here to know
how fond I am of that sort of thing.
I don't think I want any cabbage.
Couldn't we send next door for some...
No, don't!
Stevie! Stevie!
- You've heard?
- Yes.
I'm terribly sorry.
I don't know what to say.
- You know why I'm here.
- Yes.
I'll have to arrest him.
Yes.
I'll help him if I can, of course.
For your sake, if not for his.
I'd do anything for you. You
know that, don't you?
That's very good of you, Ted.
There isn't anything you can
do for either of us.
Things aren't as bad as that.
The evidence is against him, I admit. But
nothing's going to happen to you.
I know this isn't a very good
time to tell you.
I shouldn't tell you at all,
I suppose.
But... before I take him along,
I want you to know that...
...what happens to you means
to a lot me.
I didn't want to tell you how I felt
about you, but there it is.
I guess I'd better get my coat if we're
going. I can't stop shivering.
- For God's sake, what happened?
- He killed Stevie.
- I feel warmer now. Let's go.
- Go where?
- To the police, of course.
- No. Hold on! Wait a minute.
Take a look at this book!
Do you realise what this
means to you?
- Listen to me. You can't go through with this.
- Ted, let me go.
You're not guilty. I know it was an accident.
Anyway, you only did the hangman's job for him.
- Please, let me go.
- I know the facts, but no one else does.
What chance would you stand
with a judge and jury?
I don't care anymore.
You're telling me you've nothing more
to live for. Is that it?
Look at me.
Ted!
My dear, we're going to get out
of all this. Clear out.
- You know it's no good. You'd just ruin yourself.
- Oh, to hell with that!
It's Saturday night. We don't need passports for
the Continent if we ask for weekend tickets.
The train leaves at nine.
Will someone try and get in that room?
Mrs Jones or anyone?
Mrs Jones comes in at eight
o'clock in the morning.
Eight o'clock? And you say
we've got no chance?
Why, we've twelve hours start before
anyone can find him.
You shut up! I don't want to hear
another word from you.
Now, go straight to that cinema and bring that birdcage
right back - before the police get there and find it.
How could you be so mad as
to do such a thing?!
- A birdcage with a bomb in it.
- My dear, I couldn't help...
Well, you can help now. Here's your
hat and your coat.
- My dear, but what of the risk?
- Risk? Who to? You?
What about me and the child? Haven't our
lives been one long risk for months?
Now, go on. Get into that taxi.
And get that birdcage!
Bijou Cinema, Penfork Road.
Follow that taxi.
Put this through to the Yard.
- "Police van..." What's our number?
- UDC4768.
Man under observation
has just left bird shop..."
"...is making for the Bijou cinema,
in a taxi which we are following."
"Any instructions?"
“Arrest man and Verloc
on arrival at cinema."
"Chief Inspector coming from Yard.”
I'm all right now. I just...
You mustn't look as though
you've been crying.
- I'm all right.
- Come on.
Ted?
Whatever happens...
Is Mr Verloc in?
What is it?
Police.
- Come on.
- Not that way.
- Are you in charge?
- Sorry. No time now, madam.
- But I'm Mrs Verloc.
- Oh! Where have you been, Spencer?
Look here, sir...
He was just taking me along
to the police station.
Oh, I see. Does Mrs Verloc know we
want to question her?
Yes, he's explained all that. I told him
I wanted to make a statement.
- Statement, eh? What kind of statement?
- Mrs Verloc, you can make your...
...statement later, at the station.
All right, Spencer. I'm in charge of this.
Is the statement to do with your husband?
- The old man's gone through to the back, sir.
- Right, I'm coming over.
You wait here. Your husband will
be along in a minute.
- It's no...
- But, Mrs Verloc!
Yes, no time now, I'm afraid. Later. You
stay here by the car, Spencer.
How many men have gone
round the back?
Mr Verloc?
- Mr Verloc?
- Come on, grandpa. Open up.
- It'll save a lot of trouble.
- You open that door, I'll blow the place sky high!
- Perhaps he's got a bomb?
- Half a tick. Better clear the cinema!
- I'll look after the old man.
- No, thanks. I'm staying here.
- You've got a wife.
- All the more reason why I should stop.
Go on - get the audience out.
He's gone to the back. He's got a bomb.
Says he's going to use it.
Bomb? Ls Verloc inside too'?
I don't know. Perhaps something's
happened to him.
Ladies and gentlemen, I must ask you
all to leave the cinema.
- Mrs Verloc, is your husband inside there?
- She knows nothing, sir!
- Why do you keep interfering, Spencer?
- Yes, he's inside.
The old man's got a bomb. What's your
husband's nerve like? Can he control him?
- No.
- He can't?
He's dead!
The roof's gone. The whole of the back
of the place - clean blown off.
Anybody...?
All the audience was clear,
thank goodness.
God, I saw some things in
the war, but...
- ls there enough left to identify?
- I wouldn't say so, sir.
You'd better get a first-aid man to
attend to that head of yours.
Spencer.
You'd better look after Mrs Verloc. Her
husband's dead - blown to glory.
You can break it to her.
There'll be a few enquiries later.
There's nothing against her,
so far as I can gather.
Yes, sir.
- Make way, there.
- That's queer!
Is that girl psychic? She said
that Verloc was...
Dead, sir? Well, you don't need second
sight in a case like this.
But she said it before.
Or was it after...?
I can't remember.